what is the artist's relationship with
his art in other words an artist creates
something in the world he might have an
original vision a glimpse of inspiration
a holy moment and he's able to somehow
transcribe somehow assemble somehow
concoct
some kind of output song lyric a poem a
film of painting something that someone
can behold right and people right if the
work of art is true that people will
marvel people will gawk people will lose
themselves beholding the work they will
associate that experience with the
artist himself and what pressure no
relationship can bear the burden of
godhood
the kind of idolatry that successful
artists are her are put through is
something that you must be careful what
you wish for that is a lot of
expectation right why do people marvel
at great art they marvel at great art
because as jordan peterson says the
transcendent shines through the mattes
and partially articulated form right the
artist was able to tap into something
larger than himself right it comes
through us but not from us and though it
is with us it belongs not to us
divine inspiration no doubt is a work of
cosmic alchemy when you output something
transcendent it will shake the war
world with its quaking annihilating
glory no doubt but it's that exorcism it
is that creative metabolic process that
also nourishes the artist the artist
will never be satisfied with just
creating one singular work of art I have
had the experience of outputting lots of
video content that is my truth at my
highest moments in life and what happens
is I have a relationship with my work I
make a series of videos people resonate
with the anthemic reverie that perhaps
I've been able to capture in a dizzying
frenzy and then people resonate with the
content that'll say to me wow a small
distance between me and that work if
that work was recent if I'm have having
regular downloads and regular dives into
my own creativity that I can receive the
compliment the artist can say wow thank
you I'm glad my work has resonated with
you I know why it has because I feel
connected with the very process that has
produced that work but what's happened
what so often happens is that as artists
we might be privy to one two or three
moments of divine inspiration we might
output something great once or twice and
then people will forever associate us
with that work and we ourselves cannot
seem to return to the Wow to the
inspiration to the ah it's the
existential writer's block it's like wow
I've written a hit book and now
everybody knows me for that book and
every time they tell me wow I love your
book I'm feeling a fire in the belly and
and anxiety from the fact that I haven't
written anything original in a while we
are only defined we measure our
self-worth by the last piece of art that
we've created and the more distance of
time exists between us and our art the
more we start to feel a kind of imposter
syndrome the more we start to feel a
kind of fraudulence this more we start
to feel like we're not living up to who
we have pretended to the world that we
can be because of a singular moment
visionary inspiration and so the
question becomes can an artist ever come
up with a formula to create more art can
he come up with a recipe to inspire the
poetic reverie that will lead to some
kind of exhilarating output that he can
be proud of can an artist stay creative
can an artist have longevity can he
continue to be prolific in his art this
has become the challenge of my life and
this my friends I believe you guys can
no doubt relate to is how do we come up
with a way of reproducibility and
repeatability how can we make ecstasy
the creative flow of the artist a place
that you can go back to again and again
and again to make of our lives work of
art your life is lived in individual
moments and it is up to us to make sure
those moments are final interconnected
and grand to make a masterpiece out of
life to constantly output life a life we
would output art to lively willingly
live again and again for all of eternity
this is what we can strive for and our
March my friend our expressions are
creativity our poems and our songs
the digital paper trails that believe in
our way showing the path
this is the question every artists out
there to figure out an answer for
himself